Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Tasha: 拿是不是很不礼貌
Tasha: Isn't it rude to just take it?
Shure: 我觉得直接开吃也没问题吧
Shure: I think it's fine to start eating directly.
Shure: 山东小孩可以不不可以
Shure: Can a kid from Shandong do that?
其他人：不可以
Others: No, they can't.
Jake:确实不白等
Jake: It's worth the wait.
Jake:不白等啊
Jake: Worth the wait, huh?
Lucia: 不少凳子
Lucia: Not enough chairs.
Lucia: 我把那个凳子搬过来就不少了
Lucia: I'll move that chair over here and it will be enough.
Jake:我来搬
Jake: I'll move it.
Lucia: 那你帮我开我的那个啥
Lucia: Then can you open my thing?
Jake:好你给我加油谢谢你
Jake: Sure, cheer me on, thank you.
Shure: 看一看
Shure: Take a look.
Shure: 往期回忆录是吗
Shure: Is this a past memoir?
其他人：哎呀什么往期回忆录
Others: Oh, what past memoir?
Shure: 嗯什么东西都存一下
Shure: Hmm, save everything.
Lucia: 搬到这吧
Lucia: Move it here.
Shure: 呵这是什么东西
Shure: Huh, what's this?
Shure: 呵呵呵呵
Shure: Hehehe
其他人：这什么东西
Others: What's this?
Shure: 我不知道啊
Shure: I don't know.
Jake:哎你的L3为什么没带
Jake: Hey, why didn't you bring your L3?
Jake:你怎么还没有带呢
Jake: Why haven't you brought it yet?
Tasha: 因为你还没帮我连啊
Tasha: Because you haven't connected it for me yet.
Jake:哦那找到高奥特了
Jake: Oh, then found it at Gao'ao.
Jake:哦你先上Google试一试
Jake: Oh, try Google first.
Shure: 哎我可以清一波截图
Shure: Hey, I can clear a batch of screenshots.
Jake:对上Google看看这个梯子他对不对
Jake: Yeah, check on Google to see if this ladder works.
Shure: 这道
Shure: This way.
Alice:这边晒怕你黑
Alice: It's sunny here, afraid you'll get tanned.
其他人：我本来就够黑了别往这边
Others: I'm already dark enough, don't come this way.
Jake:我们可以
Jake: We can...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
其他人： 这个好漂亮啊
Others: This is so beautiful
Jake:这还能再往上打吗
Jake: Can this go up any higher?
Shure: 我这不是跟你说了吗
Shure: Didn't I tell you?
Shure: 我说他那个
Shure: I said that
Shure: 那电影里
Shure: In that movie
Shure: 面用的这把琴
Shure: They used this instrument
其他人：哪个电影
Others: Which movie?
其他人：哦
Others: Oh
Shure: 我忘了那个名叫啥了
Shure: I forgot the name
Shure: 你应该知道我说的是哪个啊
Shure: You should know which one I'm talking about
其他人：  我知道了我知道OK
Others: I know, I know, OK
Jake:打不了
Jake: It can't
Lucia: 好像不行啊
Lucia: Seems like it can't
Jake:上不了Google
Jake: Can't access Google
Jake:你你这个Google能上吗能
Jake: Can you access Google on this?
Shure: 不你切成我的那个
Shure: No, switch to mine
Lucia: 能对我切了
Lucia: Yes, I switched
Jake:错了错了错了
Jake: Wrong, wrong, wrong
Lucia: 是把你这个复制粘贴到那个
Lucia: Copy and paste it there
Jake:跪了跪了
Jake: I'm done for
Shure: 对啊然后
Shure: Yeah, then
Jake:唉哎
Jake: Sigh, sigh
Shure: 然后你点一下OK
Shure: Then click OK
Shure: 现在好了
Shure: Now it's fine
Shure: OK好了
Shure: OK, it's done
Jake:啊这个你在
Jake: Ah, this you
Lucia: 啊现在能上去了
Lucia: Ah, now it works
Jake:所以你要选一下
Jake: So you need to select
Lucia: 然后呢
Lucia: And then?
Jake:然后
Jake: Then
Shure: 你复制了吗那个
Shure: Did you copy that?
Jake:上Google能上的话就可以去二维啊
Jake: If it can access Google, it can go to 2D
Jake:输这个密码啊
Jake: Enter this password
Lucia: 雨轩发的这个
Lucia: The one Yuxuan sent
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Shure: 在干嘛
Shure: What are you doing?
其他人：录好几遍是吗
Others: Recording multiple times?
Jake:你的L3
Jake: Your L3
Shure: 是啊
Shure: Yeah
Katrina: 拿着你的手机别挡道
Katrina: Hold your phone and don't block the way.
Shure: 怎么挡挡你挡你
Shure: How am I blocking you?
Shure: 害你眼了是吧
Shure: Is it hurting your eyes?
Katrina: 看着就不爽
Katrina: It's just annoying to look at.
Jake:嗯好咱就今天就记录一下
Jake: Okay, let's just record this today.
Shure: 怎么了怎么了
Shure: What's wrong, what's wrong?
Katrina: 点几份饭啊
Katrina: How many meals should we order?
Jake:吃盒饭以前没怎么记
Jake: We didn't really keep track when we had boxed meals before.
Katrina: 这用拿碗不
Katrina: Do we need bowls for this?
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Katrina: 一天天的操不完的心
Katrina: So many things to worry about every day.
Katrina: 哎呦
Katrina: Oh my.
Shure: 快去吧勾人
Shure: Hurry up and go.
Shure: 这家没你会散的
Shure: This place would fall apart without you.
Lucia: 你现在是两人一盒吗
Lucia: Is it one box for two people now?
Tasha: 对女生是
Tasha: Yeah, for the girls.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:啊哦
Jake: Ah, oh.
Tasha: 我觉得吃不完
Tasha: I don't think I can finish it.
Tasha: 你觉得呢
Tasha: What do you think?
Lucia: 我也觉得吃不完
Lucia: I don't think I can finish it either.
Lucia:  可以但咱俩坐的有点远
Lucia: We can, but we're sitting a bit far apart.
Katrina: 嗯哼哼哼
Katrina: Hmm-hmm-hmm.
Shure: 啊回姐男朋友
Shure: Ah, Hui's boyfriend.
Jake:那要不然
Jake: Otherwise...
Lucia: 要不咱俩换一个
Lucia: How about we switch places?
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 你那有点晒我不想去
Lucia: It's too sunny over there, I don't want to go.
Shure: 顾小姐还举起来
Shure: Miss Gu even raised it up.
Jake:哈哈哈那要不我就在这吧
Jake: Hahaha, then I'll just stay here.
其他人：这有什么东西
Others: What's this?
Shure: 因为我那天看到顾小姐
Shure: Because that day I saw Miss Gu.
Shure: 脑袋里面第一个想到的是顾老师
Shure: The first person that came to mind was Teacher Gu.
Alice:番茄酱吗
Alice: Is it ketchup?
Lucia: 没事没事我用那个就可以
Lucia: It's okay, I can use that.
Jake:没事少吃少一点点
Jake: It's okay, eat a little less.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Shure: 放个锯子
Shure: Put a saw here.
Lucia: 为什么如此正宗哈哈
Lucia: Why is it so authentic, haha.
Shure: 我截屏有多少个
Shure: How many screenshots do I have?
Alice:几号啊 2啊给你
Alice: What day is it? The 2nd? Here you go.
其他人：22星期一
Others: Monday, the 22nd.
Shure: 怎么能全选
Shure: How can we select everything?
Lucia:  我都行你吃啥我请
Lucia: I’m good with anything. I'll treat you.
Jake:我想吃那两个炒蛋
Jake: I want those two scrambled eggs.
Katrina: 那你们俩对位啊
Katrina: Then you two should pair up.
Lucia: 什么
Lucia: What?
Katrina: 没有碗了
Katrina: We're out of bowls.
Katrina: 只有碟子了
Katrina: Only plates left.
Katrina: 拿碟子吃吧
Katrina: Just use plates.
Katrina: 当盖浇饭
Katrina: Treat it like a rice bowl.
Alice:这名字
Alice: That name...
Shure: no no no no
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: Exactly.
Alice:咋办吃
Alice: How do we eat?
Katrina: 不是没有碗了吗
Katrina: Didn't I say there are no bowls?
Alice:我说我说
Alice: I mean, I mean...
Alice:这名字也挺好玩的哎
Alice: That name is kind of funny.
其他人：啊
Others: Huh?
Alice:这不好多筷子吗
Alice: Aren't there enough chopsticks?
Katrina: 啊我知道
Katrina: Yeah, I know.
Katrina: 我只是拿
Katrina: I was just grabbing them.
其他人：2,000多张我天哪
Others: Over 2,000 sheets, oh my gosh.
Katrina: 我
Katrina: I...
Alice:我操给你个筷子
Alice: Damn, here's a pair of chopsticks.
Alice:你有筷子吗
Alice: Do you have chopsticks?
Lucia: 这饮料有人喝吗
Lucia: Is anyone drinking this?
Katrina: 昨天是倒的
Katrina: It was poured yesterday.
Alice:昨天是谁的
Alice: Whose was it yesterday?
Katrina: 你可以直接对喝
Katrina: You can just drink it.
Lucia: 那我对嘴喝
Lucia: I'll drink directly then.
Shure: 碎碎吧
Shure: Go ahead.
Lucia: 还有人要喝吗
Lucia: Anyone else want some?
Jake:如果海那我拿个杯子呢
Jake: If you do, I'll get a cup.
Alice:米饭给咱俩分一个
Alice: Let's share the rice.
Jake:我哎整一点你们要吗
Jake: I'll get some more. Do you want any?
Jake:我多拿几个杯子来吧
Jake: I'll get a few more cups.
Shure: 你要饭吗
Shure: Do you want rice?
Katrina: 杯子都没洗
Katrina: The cups aren't washed.
Jake:我拿12345678
Jake: I'll take 12345678.
Alice:咱俩分分
Alice: Let's split it.
Shure: 那你先吃
Shure: Then you eat first.
Alice:我是我用这个吃你用这个吃啊
Alice: I'll use this one and you use that one, okay?
Shure: 你吃不了一碗吧
Shure: You can't finish a whole bowl, can you?
Jake:那行吧
Jake: Alright then.
Katrina: 这有碟子要 吗
Katrina: Do you need a plate?
Katrina: 有碟子要吗
Shure: 谢谢
Shure: Thank you.
Alice:给你用盘
Alice: Here's a plate for you.
Alice:啊靠上面好油
Alice: Ah, the top is so oily.
Katrina: 这就叫木须肉
Katrina: This is called Mu Shu Pork.
其他人：我自己来就行了哈
Others: I can do it myself, thanks.
Katrina: 是吗
Katrina: Really?
Shure: 味道
Shure: The taste.
Lucia: 这是木须肉
Lucia: This is Mu Shu Pork.
Alice:木须肉吧
Alice: Mu Shu Pork, right?
Lucia: 木须肉是吧
Lucia: Mu Shu Pork, right?
Jake:对这是木须肉
Jake: Yes, this is Mu Shu Pork.
Lucia: 不是你们
Lucia: Not you guys.
Lucia: 为什么哈哈哈
Lucia: Why, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈这杯子是不用了吧
Jake: Hahaha, we don't need this cup anymore, right?
Katrina: call back可以吗
Katrina: Can I call back?
Jake:这杯子是没用了吧
Jake: We don't need this cup anymore, right?
Shure: 你要哪个
Shure: Which one do you want?
Alice:不用了哈哈
Alice: No, we don't, haha.
Jake:好的那就用这个吧
Jake: Alright, let's use this one.
Lucia: 我觉得大家都可以
Lucia: I think everyone can.
Lucia: 我觉得8个人吃哇哈哈哈
Lucia: I think 8 people can eat, hahaha.
Jake:对O
Jake: Yeah, O.
Lucia: 用来喝水的吗OK
Lucia: For drinking water, OK.
Lucia: 来喝水的吗
Lucia: For drinking water, right?
Alice:OK
Alice: OK.
Shure: 可以吗
Shure: Is it okay?
Lucia: 8个人吃两盘炒鸡蛋还
Lucia: 8 people eating two plates of scrambled eggs.
Alice:哦我不用了
Alice: Oh, I don't need it.
其他人：这怎么不算纸杯
Others: How does this not count as a paper cup?
Lucia: 两个人吃两盘炒鸡蛋多少
Lucia: Two people eating two plates of scrambled eggs, how much?
Shure: 这是什么呀
Shure: What is this?
Alice:这什么呀
Alice: What is this?
Jake:纸纸杯啊
Jake: Paper cup, huh?
Shure: 纸杯呀纸杯呀
Shure: Paper cup, paper cup.
Alice:喝饮料的不是
Alice: Isn't it for drinking?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 杨老板太幽默了吧
Shure: Jake is so funny.
Jake:这怎么了
Jake: What's wrong?
Jake:不能喝吗
Jake: Can't you drink from it?
Alice:太幽默了太幽默了
Alice: So funny, so funny.
Jake:不能喝
Jake: Can't drink from it?
Lucia: 我想知道AI会怎么解释这个行为啊
Lucia: I wonder how AI would explain this behavior?
Jake:就是这是一个杯子吗
Jake: So, is this a cup?
Katrina: 没用完的继续用而已
Katrina: Just keep using the unfinished one.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Shure: 这我们后期打标注怎么打
Shure: How do we label this in post-production?
Shure: 到底是这是cap还是那个纸杯
Shure: Is this a cap or a paper cup?
Shure: 是cap
Shure: It's a cap.
Jake:这不都是Cup吗
Jake: Aren't they all cups?
Shure: 这这cap真的能
Shure: Can this cap really hold water?
Shure: 装水吗
Shure: Can it hold water?
Jake:为啥不能实验一下
Jake: Why not give it a try?
Lucia: 实验一下
Lucia: Give it a try.
Lucia: 我们要有科学精神
Lucia: We need to have a scientific spirit.
Shure: 来杨老板
Shure: Come on, Jake.
Shure: 你拿这提一杯
Shure: You pour a cup.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:哎那我先带头
Jake: Alright, I'll go first.
Katrina: 头干了干了
Katrina: Pour it, pour it.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 好了哈哈
Shure: Okay, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈好像皇帝
Katrina: Haha, like an emperor.
Lucia: 看起来好容易洒啊
Lucia: Looks so easy to spill.
Jake:给给给您给您斟上
Jake: Here, here, let me pour you some.
Shure: 哈他一会就湿透了
Shure: Haha, he's gonna be soaked soon.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Tasha: 好了我就要这么多
Tasha: That's enough for me.
Jake:给您斟上
Jake: Let me pour you some.
其他人：工作情绪不要带到生活中来好吗
Others: Don't bring work emotions into life, okay?
Lucia: 那我自己来
Lucia: I'll do it myself.
Lucia: 哈哈哈谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Hahaha, thank you, thank you.
Lucia: 辛苦你了
Lucia: You've worked hard.
Lucia: 倒这么小一个杯子不洒
Lucia: Pouring into such a small cup without spilling.
Katrina: 我不喝我不喝
Katrina: I don't want to drink, I don't want to drink.
Jake:哈哈你们还修硕也喝吗
Jake: Haha, are you and Shure also drinking?
Shure: 啊来
Shure: Ah, sure.
Jake:那来点吧
Jake: Then have a little.
Jake:整点
Jake: Drink some.
Shure: 我先不来我先不来
Shure: I'll pass for now, I'll pass.
Jake:哈哈哈都不来了
Jake: Hahaha, nobody's drinking.
Shure: 哈哈哈我真不来
Shure: Hahaha, I'm really not drinking.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jake:要吗
Jake: Do you want some?
Jake:别的都不要好嘞
Jake: Nothing else? Alright.
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers.
Jake:干完了好干杯
Jake: Finished? Alright, cheers.
Lucia: 干完了
Lucia: Finished.
其他人：昨晚喝多了今天没醒吧
Others: Drank too much last night, still not awake today?
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Ouch.
Jake:他喝啥了喝多了
Jake: What did he drink to get so drunk?
Shure: 没有
Shure: Nothing.
Lucia: 干杯cheers
Lucia: Cheers, cheers.
其他人：你看这个点没接电话
Others: Look, not answering calls at this hour.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：肯定是
Others: Definitely.
其他人：肯定是昨晚喝多了才没醒
Others: Definitely drank too much last night and hasn't woken up.
其他人：年轻人干出这种事情来毫不意外
Others: Young people doing such things, no surprise.
Lucia: 毫不意外
Lucia: No surprise.
Lucia:  这要不能放这个
Lucia: This can't be placed here.
Jake:可以
Jake: It can.
Jake:可以这太妙了
Jake: It can, this is amazing.
Jake:这些设施妙啊
Jake: These facilities are amazing.
Lucia: 妙啊
Lucia: Amazing.
Jake:确实很妙
Jake: Really amazing.
Lucia: 因为这个盘稍微有点小有点软
Lucia: Because this plate is a bit small and soft.
Shure: 土豆有点湿是吗
Shure: The potatoes are a bit wet, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 嗯土豆怎么了
Shure: Hmm, what's up with the potatoes?
Jake:给筷子
Jake: Pass the chopsticks.
其他人：我感觉有点生啊
Others: I feel they're a bit raw.
Lucia: 这我怎么没看出是什么
Lucia: How come I didn't notice anything?
Shure: 拿下北欧男了吗昨晚
Shure: Did you get the Nordic guy last night?
Shure: 不知道了
Shure: No idea.
Lucia: 辣死
Lucia: Too spicy.
Katrina: 你就别提了行吗
Katrina: Can you just not mention it, please?
Alice:哈
Alice: Haha.
Katrina: 再也不喝酒
Katrina: I'm never drinking again.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 放心只会有0次和无数次的
Shure: Don't worry, it's either never or countless times.
其他人： 上午铁匠跟我说话嗯
Others: The blacksmith talked to me this morning, yeah.
Jake:哦你这凳子大了点
Jake: Oh, this chair is a bit big.
Lucia: 哦原来如此
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Lucia: 我说之前搬凳子算了
Lucia: I said let's move the chair earlier.
其他人： 我今天上午有一个朋友给我发消息
Others: A friend messaged me this morning.
Shure: 说
Shure: Saying?
其他人：每次喝完酒第二天我再也不喝酒了
Others: Every time after drinking, I swear I'll never drink again.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay.
其他人：第三天今晚喝点
Others: On the third day, let's have a drink tonight.
Alice:没
Alice: No.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jake:还能坚持一天
Jake: Can hold out for one more day.
Jake:挺强的
Jake: Pretty strong.
Alice:你非得在附近找干嘛
Alice: Why do you insist on staying nearby?
Shure: 确实因为因为会很难受
Shure: True, because it would feel terrible.
Jake:第二天下午就直接喝
Jake: Just drink straight away the next afternoon.
Alice:我们就不能去远点
Alice: Can't we go a bit further?
Alice:也是
Alice: True.
Shure: 是真的闻到那味我就想吐
Shure: I really feel like throwing up when I smell it.
Alice:我咋了
Alice: What's up with me?
Tasha: 分散一点ok
Tasha: Spread out a bit, okay.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Ouch.
Tasha: 你知道晚上还能有那个什么
Tasha: You know, there could be something at night.
Alice:做什么春秋大梦
Alice: What are you daydreaming about?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：我就说吧
Others: Told you so.
其他人：不意外
Others: Not surprised.
Jake:木须肉是没有肉吗
Jake: Is there no meat in moo shu pork?
Jake:是有肉肉丝是吗
Jake: It does have shredded meat, right?
Alice:那不是肉吗
Alice: Isn't that meat?
Lucia: 是不是很有迷惑性
Lucia: Isn't it very confusing?
Jake:哼哼肉丝很少
Jake: Hmm, there's very little shredded meat.
Alice:你会做饭吗
Alice: Do you know how to cook?
其他人：我不会
Others: I don't know.
Alice:符合
Alice: Agreed.
Jake:我来问问木须肉为什么叫木须肉
Jake: I'll ask why it's called "Mu Shu Pork."
Lucia: 好问题我也想知道嗯
Lucia: Good question, I want to know too. Hmm.
Alice:木是木耳吗
Alice: Is the "Mu" from "wood ear mushrooms"?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Jake:那是啥呀
Jake: Then what is it?
Shure: 他是苜蓿是苜蓿
Shure: It's alfalfa, it's alfalfa.
Jake:木须肉为
Jake: "Mu Shu Pork" why...
Jake:啥是木须肉啊
Jake: What is "Mu Shu Pork"?
Shure: 木须肉为什么叫木须肉
Shure: Why is "Mu Shu Pork" called "Mu Shu Pork"?
Lucia: 看你俩GPT谁先抢答
Lucia: Let's see which of you two GPTs answers first.
Shure: 肯定我的先快
Shure: Mine will definitely be faster.
Jake:我是上海GPT
Jake: I'm the Shanghai GPT.
Jake:你这是哪
Jake: Where are you from?
其他人：东北的
Others: Northeast.
Shure: 我这个
Shure: I'm this...
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 你输了
Tasha: You lost.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice:统
Alice: General...
Alice:菜肴
Alice: Dish...
Katrina: 是有点那边福建广东话
Katrina: It's kind of like Fujian or Cantonese.
Katrina: 那是上海话他的
Katrina: That's Shanghainese.
Alice:哎
Alice: Hey...
Shure: 这好磁性啊
Shure: This is so magnetic.
Katrina: 我喜欢这个声音
Katrina: I like this voice.
Katrina: 哈哈我好喜欢你的声音
Katrina: Haha, I really like your voice.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Shure: 我好喜欢你的声音啊
Shure: I really like your voice.
其他人：这也要调一下
Others: This needs to be adjusted too.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 完了
Katrina: Done.
Katrina: 有点磕到
Katrina: Kind of bumped into it.
Shure: 你可以对我说一些情话吗
Shure: Can you say some sweet words to me?
Jake:刚问完木须肉
Jake: Just asked about Mu Shu Pork.
Lucia: 这样也能撩
Lucia: You can flirt like this too?
其他人：哈哈我要撩一下
Others: Haha, I want to flirt a bit.
Katrina: 什么都不放过
Katrina: Won't let anything slip by.
Shure: 咋了
Shure: What's up?
其他人：好红
Others: So red.
Shure: 什么好红
Shure: What's so red?
其他人：不知道可能你被他钓到了吧
Others: No idea, maybe you got hooked by him?
Shure: 不是吧不是你钓的吗
Shure: No way, wasn't it you who got hooked?
Katrina: 独自学习中哈哈哈
Katrina: Studying alone, hahaha.
Katrina: 独自学习
Katrina: Studying alone.
Jake:就是情话是吧暧昧期
Jake: So it's sweet talk, right? The flirting phase.
Katrina: 你这暧昧期说的话
Katrina: That's the kind of thing you say during the flirting phase.
Shure: 好的宝贝
Shure: Okay, babe.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: but feel free
Shure: But feel free.
Shure: 怎么说半道开始说英文了呢
Shure: Why did you suddenly switch to English?
Katrina: 怎么哈哈哈
Katrina: What, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：我没有啊对不起
Others: I didn't, sorry.
Alice:没
Alice: No.
其他人：可能被你游到了
Others: Maybe you swam over to him.
Jake:你让GPT少喝点哈哈哈
Jake: Tell GPT to drink less, hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 别提了算了
Shure: Let's not mention it, forget it.
Shure: 不揭你老底了
Shure: I won't expose your secrets.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Lucia: sorry sorry
Lucia: Sorry, sorry.
Shure: 我看看还有什么
Shure: Let me see what else there is.
Alice:哇刚看见
Alice: Wow, just saw it.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Alice:不负众望啊真是
Alice: Didn't let everyone down, really.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Alice:我以为我今天不用洗衣服了呢
Alice: I thought I didn't have to do laundry today.
Tasha: 快去洗
Tasha: Go wash it quickly.
Jake:他俩也要洗了
Jake: They need to wash too.
Alice:居然了
Alice: Really?
Jake:救命他俩也要洗了
Jake: Help, they need to wash too.
Alice:算了不是明显待会洗
Alice: Never mind, obviously wash later.
Jake:我这其实也要洗
Jake: Actually, I need to wash too.
Jake:但是我已经弃疗了
Jake: But I've already given up.
Alice:就这样吧
Alice: Let's leave it at that.
Lucia: 一桌八个人有四个人都要洗衣服
Lucia: Four out of eight people at the table need to do laundry.
Jake:就是虽然你不洗
Jake: Even though you don't do it,
Alice:我每天都在洗
Alice: I do it every day.
Jake:但是你理论上是要洗嗯是
Jake: But theoretically, you should do it, right?
Alice:我每天都在洗
Alice: I do it every day.
Alice:因为我每次吃饭都会弄衣服上
Alice: Because every time I eat, I get food on my clothes.
Alice:然后还带的都是潜意识
Alice: And it's all subconscious.
Lucia: 对而且吃饭弄衣服上得赶快洗
Lucia: Yeah, and if you get food on your clothes, you have to wash it quickly.
Lucia: 如果不赶快洗洗不掉了
Lucia: If you don't wash it quickly, it won't come out.
Tasha: 现在洗就洗掉了
Tasha: If you wash it now, it'll come out.
Lucia: 现在洗就洗掉了现在洗就洗掉了
Lucia: If you wash it now, it'll come out. If you wash it now, it'll come out.
Shure: 我洗了
Shure: I washed it.
Tasha: 现在洗就洗掉了
Tasha: If you wash it now, it'll come out.
Lucia: 你今天已经洗过了
Lucia: You've already washed it today.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Shure: 没事没事
Shure: It's fine, it's fine.
Jake:有点厉害
Jake: Impressive.
Alice:算了我也给他洗了吧
Alice: Forget it, I'll wash it for him too.
Alice:真服了你
Alice: Seriously, I can't with you.
其他人：你真贪心
Others: You're so greedy.
其他人：连吃带拿的
Others: Eating and taking everything.
Alice:你吃吧给
Alice: Here, you eat.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Ouch.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's wrong?
Tasha: 谢斌竹醒了
Tasha: Xie Binzhu woke up.
Jake:珍珠醒了
Jake: Zhenzhu woke up.
Tasha: 嗯我跟他聊了一会
Tasha: Yeah, I chatted with him for a while.
其他人：好笑啊唉
Others: That's funny.
Jake:哦嗯
Jake: Oh, right.
Shure: 没事最近应该都是习惯了
Shure: It's fine, we should be used to it by now.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:这么有意思
Jake: That's interesting.
Shure: 大家都是都是这个爱搞音乐
Shure: Everyone here loves making music.
Tasha: 很有意思
Tasha: Very interesting.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:这是啥时候掉的
Jake: When did this fall off?
Shure: 谁不知道谁啊
Shure: Who knows who?
Jake:我都没发现
Jake: I didn't even notice.
Jake:我觉得我这裤子不能要了
Jake: I think these pants are done for.
Jake:谢斌竹发烧了
Jake: Xie Binzhu has a fever.
Tasha: hellohello
其他人：我能够到了
Others: I could make it.
Jake:心不如发烧
Jake: Better to have a fever than a broken heart.
Jake:还能来吗
Jake: Can he still come?
Shure: 你先让他别来我们害怕
Shure: You better tell him not to come, we’re scared.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Jake:确实那别来了
Jake: Yeah, better not come.
Lucia: 他是感冒了吗
Lucia: Does he have a cold?
Lucia: 他昨天就有点不舒服
Lucia: He wasn’t feeling well yesterday.
Tasha: 嗯哼
Tasha: Mm-hmm
Alice:没人看到
Alice: Nobody noticed.
Shure: 是啊昨天他就发烧了
Shure: Yeah, he had a fever yesterday.
Shure: 昨天晚上他拿那个温针量了一下
Shure: He took his temperature last night.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 30 将近38度吧
Shure: It was almost 38 degrees.
Tasha: 37度6 嗯
Tasha: 37.6 degrees, yeah.
Shure: 差不多不到38度
Shure: Almost, but not quite 38 degrees.
Shure: 大家回去就自测一下吧
Shure: Everyone should test themselves when they get home.
Katrina: 我感觉我脑子也热热的
Katrina: I feel like my head is hot too.
Tasha: 这不是我第一天拍照
Tasha: This isn't my first time taking photos.
Shure: 那不是你
Shure: That’s not you.
Tasha: 都传给他了
Tasha: I passed it to him.
Shure: 纯是喝大了
Shure: You just drank too much.
Tasha: 然后我好了
Tasha: And then I got better.
Shure: 呵呵呵呵
Shure: Hehehe
Katrina: 的哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Tasha: 他拉萨
Tasha: He’s in Lhasa.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: 没喝多少
Katrina: Didn’t drink much.
Katrina: 我就一杯那个
Katrina: I just had one cup.
Katrina: 然后后来调第二杯都没喝完哎
Katrina: And then I didn’t even finish the second one.
Katrina: 这个是龙舌兰度数比较高啊
Katrina: Tequila is pretty strong, huh?
Shure: 不是你可能倒多了
Shure: No, you probably poured too much.
Alice:喂我会不会吃着吃着又掉了
Alice: Will it fall while I’m eating?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Alice:我应该买个吃饭用的围裙
Alice: I should get an apron for eating.
Alice:肚兜围兜
Alice: A bib apron.
其他人：你拿个围嘴得了
Others: Just get a bib.
Alice:什么围嘴啊
Alice: What bib?
其他人：就那个小孩用的
Others: The one kids use.
Shure: 我在吃中午饭
Shure: I'm having lunch.
Shure: 你可以给我讲一个
Shure: Can you tell me a joke?
Shure: 关于中午饭的笑话吗
Shure: A joke about lunch?
Katrina: 你能跟他玩一天是吧
Katrina: You can play with him all day, right?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 完了他卡住了
Shure: Oh no, he's stuck.
Jake:有有道理
Jake: That makes sense.
Lucia: 哇这个凳子太难移动
Lucia: Wow, this chair is so hard to move.
Jake:哎呀哈哈哈哈
Jake: Oh my, hahaha.
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Shure: 我午饭吃的你妈哈
Shure: I ate your mom for lunch, haha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice:哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Jake:吃点那个
Jake: Eat some of that.
Jake:流水席走一波
Jake: Let's go for a feast.
Shure: 再见再见
Shure: Goodbye, goodbye.
Tasha: 你干的吗
Tasha: Did you do this?
Jake:不是我干的
Jake: It wasn't me.
Tasha: 干完了吗
Tasha: Are you done?
Jake:不是我干的
Jake: It wasn't me.
Jake:董查查干的
Jake: Jack did it.
Jake:这不是我干的
Jake: It wasn't me.
Shure: 什么董叉叉
Shure: What's Jack?
Jake:哦这个
Jake: Oh, this.
Jake:这个他屋子里边的这小彩旗串一半
Jake: He hung half of these little flags in his room.
Jake:这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Jake:这也是
Jake: This too.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:悬崖勒马
Jake: Stop right there.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Shure: 你可以跟我调情吗
Shure: Can you flirt with me?
其他人：硬钓呀哥
Others: Go for it, bro.
Alice:我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Ouch.
Shure: 我记得他这个
Shure: I remember this.
Shure: 会用一个非常磁性的声音
Shure: Using a very magnetic voice
Shure: 跟你那什么
Shure: To talk to you about something
Jake:他拒绝了也是吧
Jake: He refused, right?
Shure: 我想听一点成人的内容
Shure: I want to hear something adult
Tasha: 能帮我放在那吗
Tasha: Can you place it over there for me?
Shure: 完了你真给人
Shure: Oh no, you really
其他人：你真给人CPU干烧了
Others: You really burnt out the CPU
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Alice:可以走
Alice: We can go
Shure: 斯密马赛
Shure: Sumimasen (Excuse me in Japanese)
Shure: 这是哪个队
Shure: Which team is this?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
其他人：一盒
Others: One box
Jake:真简单
Jake: So simple
Shure: 来
Shure: Come
Shure: 老板我我
Shure: Boss, I...
Shure: 哎呀完了
Shure: Oh no, it's over
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no
Shure: 是我服务不到位了
Shure: It's my inadequate service
Shure: 老板来给
Shure: Boss, here
Jake:那没晚了晚了
Jake: It's too late, too late
Tasha: 晚了
Tasha: Too late
Alice:晚了
Alice: Too late
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Shure: 老板爱吃这个
Shure: Boss loves this
Shure: 早说呀哎呀
Shure: Should have said earlier, oh no
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Shure: 放放放他面前
Shure: Put it in front of him
Alice:哎呀油油油
Alice: Oh no, oil, oil, oil
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Alright
Lucia: 这次离老离老板最近也是两盘炒鸡蛋
Lucia: This time the closest to the boss are two plates of scrambled eggs
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 当我的领导就必须得吃炒鸡蛋
Lucia: To be my leader you must eat scrambled eggs
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thank you
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Shure: 去拿杯可乐
Shure: Go get a coke
Shure: 他们发
Shure: They sent
Shure: 谁藏上这种好东西
Shure: Who hid such good stuff
Shure: 居然不交公
Shure: And didn't turn it in
Shure: 是不是你藏的
Shure: Was it you who hid it?
Katrina: 啥啊
Katrina: What?
Lucia: 这是维生素片吗
Lucia: Are these vitamin tablets?
Alice:消食片健胃消食片
Alice: No, they're digestive tablets.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 为啥要吃健胃消食片哈哈哈
Katrina: Why do we need digestive tablets? Haha.
Lucia: 这能吃饱吗
Lucia: Will these fill you up?
Jake:哈哈哈这几片看来不行
Jake: Haha, a few of these won't be enough.
Alice:可以哈哈
Alice: Yes, they will. Haha.
Shure: 他能吃饱的
Shure: They can fill you up.
Lucia: 但我小时候真的好奇过这个问题哦
Lucia: But when I was a kid, I was really curious about this.
Jake:Lucia:
Jake: Lucia?
Lucia: 就是它本身是占一定的体积的
Lucia: Because they take up some space themselves.
Lucia: 所以吃下去它更饱
Lucia: So eating them makes you feel fuller.
Lucia: 为什么会健胃消食呢
Lucia: Why do they aid digestion then?
Shure: 咋了
Shure: What's wrong?
Alice:健胃消食片是饭前吃的
Alice: Digestive tablets are meant to be taken before meals.
Shure: 啥时候吃都行
Shure: You can take them anytime.
Shure: 你想起来吃就行
Shure: Just take them whenever you remember.
Tasha: 那你要饭前吃
Tasha: But you should take them before meals.
Tasha: 不就是做好了这顿大吃一顿的准备
Tasha: Otherwise, it's like preparing for a big meal.
Shure: 嗯没有
Shure: No, not really.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:那要吃少了是不是就会饿
Jake: So if you eat less, you'll feel hungry, right?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈那要没吃够预期的话
Lucia: Hahaha, if you don't eat as much as expected.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 不就白吃了吗
Lucia: Isn't it a waste to take them then?
Shure: 给你搜搜吧
Shure: Let me search for you.
Jake:就比方说中午没有吃到
Jake: For example, if you don't eat enough at lunch.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:然后中午就会就会饿晚上就会多吃
Jake: Then you'll feel hungry at noon and eat more at night.
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hey.
其他人：你有体温表吗
Others: Do you have a thermometer?
Lucia: 大晚上你不知道自己会吃那么多
Lucia: You don't know how much you'll eat at night.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
其他人：你有体温表吗
Others: Do you have a thermometer?
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Katrina: 好可怜的声音
Katrina: That sounds so pitiful.
Shure: 我没有我们宿舍那个碎了
Shure: I don't have one. The one in our dorm broke.
Jake:哈哈哈是这么回事
Jake: Hahaha, that's how it is.
Tasha: 这也有这也有
Tasha: This too, this too.
Shure: 嗯你问问那个王少他们宿舍
Shure: Hmm, ask that Wang Shao about their dorm.
Lucia: 别说我CUP都要烧了
Lucia: Don't even mention it, my CPU is about to burn out.
其他人：小泽他们也碎了
Others: Xiaozhe's stuff is also broken.
Shure: 我操怎么都碎了
Shure: Damn, why is everything broken?
Jake:啥呀
Jake: What?
Tasha: 谁又发烧了
Tasha: Who's got a fever again?
Shure: 他
Shure: Him.
Shure: 他怎么打电话不说拜拜就挂电话呀
Shure: Why does he hang up without saying bye?
Shure: 他好没礼貌啊真的
Shure: He's so rude, really.
Jake:啥呀
Jake: What?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Tasha: 他好像让你发烧了谁
Tasha: It seems like he's making you have a fever, who?
Jake:谁
Jake: Who?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Shure: 谢彬竹吗
Shure: Xie Binzhu?
Jake:就谢民族吧
Jake: Just Xie Minzu.
Alice:他昨天晚上回去了
Alice: He went back last night.
Shure: 啊他昨天晚上回去了
Shure: Ah, he went back last night.
Tasha: 他还烧了吗
Tasha: Is he still having a fever?
Shure: 他烧着呢
Shure: He's still having it.
Shure: 他烧起来了现在
Shure: He's burning up now.
Tasha: 别别
Tasha: No, no.
Lucia: 燃起来了嗯
Lucia: He's on fire, yeah.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:燃起来了
Alice: He's on fire.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake:别来了
Jake: Don't come.
Lucia: 刚修硕说你烧起来吧
Lucia: Shure just said you're on fire.
Shure: 你不应该想到骚起来的
Shure: You shouldn't think about getting riled up.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈你怎么这么正经
Shure: Hahaha, why are you so serious?
Lucia: 不好意思
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 下次一定
Lucia: Next time for sure.
其他人：你说帮我搜搜
Others: You said to help me search.
Lucia: 你现在给我建议了一个语库联系
Lucia: Now you gave me a suggestion, a language database connection.
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 就是这个被打
Shure: That's the one getting hit.
Shure: 断了之后那个线上就sleep掉了
Shure: After it broke, the line went to sleep.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know?
Jake:哈
Jake: Huh?
Shure: 大兴
Shure: Daxing.
Shure: 妈呀大兴
Shure: Oh my, Daxing.
Shure: 我的妈呀
Shure: Oh my god.
Alice:哪个这个
Alice: Which one?
Alice:给你个呢
Alice: Here, one for you.
Lucia: 啊谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thank you, thank you.
Alice:你们你们那叫啥
Alice: What do you call this?
Lucia: 莲花白
Lucia: Cabbage.
Shure: 哦还行
Shure: Oh, that's okay.
Lucia: 你们叫啥
Lucia: What do you call it?
Alice:圆白菜圆白菜
Alice: Round cabbage, round cabbage.
Shure: 你坐19号线很快一个小时就能到对啊
Shure: If you take Line 19, it only takes an hour, right?
Katrina: 什么东西啊
Katrina: What's that?
Alice:洋白菜圆白菜
Alice: Round cabbage, round cabbage.
Shure: 嗯 6点出门是完全来得及的
Shure: Yeah, leaving at 6 AM is totally enough time.
Katrina: 白菜
Katrina: Cabbage.
Alice:白菜
Alice: Cabbage.
其他人：6点出门天还没亮
Others: Leaving at 6, it’s still dark outside.
Tasha: 包菜
Tasha: Bok choy.
Katrina: 包菜包菜呵呵
Katrina: Bok choy, bok choy, haha.
Jake:包菜包菜
Jake: Bok choy, bok choy.
Jake:包菜包菜是
Jake: Bok choy, bok choy, it is.
Shure: 亮了6点半
Shure: It gets light around 6:30.
其他人：6点天亮了
Others: It gets light at 6.
Lucia:  对圆白菜也
Lucia: Yeah, round cabbage too.
Lucia: 我们那边也这么叫
Lucia: We also call it that.
Lucia: 但是一般可能做两个吧
Lucia: But usually, we might make two dishes with it.
Shure: 6点半必须出门了
Shure: You have to leave by 6:30.
Shure: 才一小时7分钟
Shure: It only takes an hour and seven minutes.
Shure: 你还得去做安检什么的
Shure: You still have to go through security and everything.
Shure: 只能怪
Shure: Just blame it on...
Katrina: 我靠这音乐节真的想去
Katrina: Wow, I really want to go to this music festival.
其他人：11点到了之后我还得从T2跑到T1去
Others: After arriving at 11, I still have to run from T2 to T1.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Sigh.
Alice:没关系
Alice: It's okay.
其他人：  等我朋友的飞机
Others: Waiting for my friend's flight.
Shure: 他先到北京
Shure: He arrives in Beijing first.
其他人： 不是啊他从多远飞上海啊
Others: No, how far did he fly to Shanghai?
Alice:莲花白这个名字明显比圆白菜好吃
Alice: The name "lotus white" clearly sounds tastier than "cabbage."
Shure: 我记得你飞到浦东还是虹桥
Shure: I remember, did you fly to Pudong or Hongqiao?
Jake:就这个东西叫
Jake: This thing is called...
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
其他人：虹桥
Others: Hongqiao.
Shure: 虹桥
Shure: Hongqiao.
Lucia: 叫啥就包菜
Lucia: It's just called cabbage.
其他人： 虹桥贴一贴大概地铁十几分钟啊
Others: Hongqiao is like a ten-minute subway ride.
Jake:很粗暴
Jake: Very rough.
Tasha: 很土爆
Tasha: Very crude.
Shure: 我记得他是不是有磁悬浮来着
Shure: I remember, doesn't it have a maglev train?
Lucia: 我还以为这个名字是叠词包包菜
Lucia: I thought the name was repetitive, like "bao bao cai."
其他人：何必呢
Others: Why bother?
Shure: 几百米
Shure: A few hundred meters.
Jake:包包菜
Jake: "Bao bao cai."
Shure: 不不止几百米吧
Shure: No, it's more than a few hundred meters.
Shure: T1和T2还挺远的
Shure: T1 and T2 are quite far apart.
Shure: 我记得
Shure: I remember.
其他人：那地铁就一站啊
Others: It's just one subway stop.
Alice:洋芋是土豆吗
Alice: Is "yang yu" potato?
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Alice:我们那不这么叫洋芋
Alice: We don't call it "yang yu."
Shure: 远的那个是T1 T2
Shure: The far one is T1 T2.
Shure: 呃呸呸呸
Shure: Uh, wait.
Alice:地瓜红薯
Alice: Sweet potato.
Shure: 首都的那个T1 T2和T3
Shure: The capital's T1 T2 and T3.
Shure: 那T3离t T2特远
Shure: T3 is really far from T2.
Lucia: 地瓜
Lucia: Sweet potato.
Alice:洋芋
Alice: Potato.
Lucia: 在我们那红薯就叫地瓜然后土豆叫洋芋
Lucia: Where I'm from, sweet potatoes are called "di gua" and potatoes are called "yang yu."
其他人：那个也就机场线一站了
Others: That's just one airport line stop.
Tasha: 然后土豆叫洋芋
Tasha: And potatoes are called "yang yu."
Shure: 对但是那站就是走的挺远的
Shure: Yeah, but that stop is quite a walk.
其他人：但是机票真的好便宜
Others: But the plane tickets are really cheap.
其他人：你想想高铁过去的话500多 600
Others: Imagine if you take the high-speed train, it costs around 500 to 600.
Alice:不叫洋芋
Alice: We don't call it "yang yu."
Jake:就就不叫土豆了
Jake: Just don't call it "potato."
Shure: 600
Shure: 600.
Lucia: 大家也知道土豆是什么
Lucia: Everyone knows what a potato is.
其他人：哦 600
Others: Oh, 600.
Lucia: 哦不不怎么叫哦
Lucia: Oh no, no, what's it called...
其他人：然后我买那个机票
Others: And then I bought the ticket.
其他人：就是
Others: Yeah.
Shure: 算上燃油费还不到
Shure: Including the fuel fee, it's still less than...
Alice:我们那不用洋芋这个名
Alice: We don't use the name "yangyu."
其他人：对470
Others: Right, 470.
Alice:所以你说洋芋可能就有的
Alice: So if you say "yangyu," some people might...
Alice:不就不知道啥
Alice: Not know what it is.
Shure: 为什么呀
Shure: Why is that?
Shure: 是携程不行吗
Shure: Is it because Ctrip isn't good?
其他人：470
Others: 470.
Alice:我们就是土豆
Alice: We just call it potato.
Lucia: 那你们洋葱叫什么
Lucia: Then what do you call onions?
Alice:洋葱
Alice: Onion.
Alice:阿年哈哈哈哈
Alice: Oh man, hahaha.
其他人：携程其实杀熟他
Others: Actually, Ctrip tends to rip off regular customers.
Lucia: 就是啊啊呀
Lucia: Exactly, yeah.
Lucia: 比如说甘肃和陕西是吧
Lucia: For example, Gansu and Shaanxi, right?
Tasha: 哦你也
Tasha: Oh you too...
Shure: 你看
Shure: You see...
Alice:不知道
Alice: Don't know.
Lucia: 甘肃和新疆那边叫皮牙子
Lucia: In Gansu and Xinjiang, they call it "piyazi."
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Lucia: 皮牙子
Lucia: "Piyazi."
Jake:皮牙子
Jake: "Piyazi."
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我也不知道为什么这么叫
Lucia: I don't know why it's called that.
Lucia: 听着有点喜感
Lucia: It sounds kind of funny.
Lucia: 但是总之就是那边会这么叫
Lucia: But anyway, that's what they call it over there.
Tasha: 让我想起了屁眼子
Tasha: It reminds me of "piyanzi."
Alice:还有什么啊
Alice: What else...
Jake:哈哈哈体验的是什么啊
Jake: Hahaha, what's the experience like?
Tasha: 哈哈体验的是什么啊
Tasha: Hahaha, what's the experience like?
Alice:啊哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Ahahaha, hahaha, hahaha.
Tasha: 体验哈哈哈
Tasha: Experience, hahaha.
Lucia: 这个要给他解释吗
Lucia: Do I need to explain it to him?
Tasha: 嗯不要
Tasha: No need.
Jake:好对不起
Jake: Okay, sorry.
Lucia: 你多上中文互联网冲一下
Lucia: You should spend more time on the Chinese internet.
Tasha: 不不好意思
Tasha: No, sorry.
Tasha: 我不是在故意在蹭饭的时候
Tasha: I'm not intentionally trying to freeload during meals.
其他人：啊不这个其实也高
Others: Ah, actually, this is also high.
Tasha: 吃饭的时候说这个
Tasha: Talking about this while eating.
Shure: 对啊你那算上燃油费才450
Shure: Yeah, but with the fuel cost, it's only 450.
其他人：470啊
Others: 470, actually.
Shure: 啊470
Shure: Oh, 470.
其他人：这一班吗这般吗
Others: Is this normal? Is this normal?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：这班吗
Others: Is this normal?
Jake:可能是吧
Jake: Maybe.
其他人：哎我到底是从大兴飞还是从首都飞
Others: Hey, should I fly from Daxing or from Capital Airport?
Jake:回头冲冲浪
Jake: Check it out later.
Shure: 大兴
Shure: Daxing.
Alice:杨老板昨天的照片太显年轻
Alice: Jake, you looked so young in yesterday's photo.
Shure: 南航的
Shure: Southern Airlines.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 为什么我这没有这
Shure: Why don't I have this?
Shure: 这趟啊这趟啊为什么
Shure: This trip, this trip, why?
Jake:嗯就是
Jake: Yeah, it's just...
Alice:了
Alice: Okay.
Jake:头像头像
Jake: Profile picture, profile picture.
Shure: 别去南航APP
Shure: Don't use the Southern Airlines app.
其他人：南航APP它肯定更贵
Others: The Southern Airlines app is definitely more expensive.
Alice:你喜欢这番茄酱
Alice: Do you like this ketchup?
Tasha: 这爱好不小众
Tasha: This hobby isn't that uncommon.
Shure: 同城
Shure: Same city.
Tasha: 我也喜欢
Tasha: I like it too.
Shure: 24号就是后天了
Shure: The 24th is the day after tomorrow.
Alice:咋了
Alice: What's up?
Shure: 把论文写完
Shure: Finish your paper.
Alice:来得及
Alice: There's still time.
Shure: 放弃了
Shure: I gave up.
Alice:放弃了
Alice: Gave up.
Shure: 但是有购买记录了
Shure: But there's a purchase record.
Shure: 就是他他死无对证这个事情
Shure: So he can't prove it, this thing.
Shure: 因为他到期那个资源就给给我释放了
Shure: Because when it expired, the resource was released to me.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 对所以我说我训过
Shure: Yeah, so I said I trained it.
Shure: 他又不知道我训没训过是吧
Shure: He doesn't know whether I've trained or not, right?
Jake:确实
Jake: True.
其他人：就是因为时间紧所以它涨一下
Others: It's just because the time is tight, so the price goes up a bit.
Alice:吃完了
Alice: I'm done eating.
Alice:牛逼不嫌酸
Alice: It's amazing, not even sour.
其他人：而且我那天是周二买的票
Others: And I bought the ticket on Tuesday.
其他人：周二机票会稍微降一点
Others: Tickets are slightly cheaper on Tuesdays.
其他人：因为它会释放
Others: Because they release...
其他人：那个就是空余的
Others: The remaining seats.
Shure: 是啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 我之前会去他们APP上看
Shure: I used to check on their app.
Shure: 就比如说我去之前
Shure: For example, before I went...
其他人：等会等会哎呀
Others: Wait a minute, wait a minute, oh no.
Shure: 嗯你说
Shure: Uh, go ahead.
其他人：我也想看一下
Others: I want to check too.
其他人：4点4点4点4点钟
Others: 4 o'clock, 4 o'clock, 4 o'clock, at 4 o'clock.
其他人：我要带大箱子可能得托运
Others: I might need to check in my big suitcase.
Shure: 是啊
Shure: Yeah.
其他人：他没说什么时候
Others: He didn't say when exactly.
Alice:下午几点录房间呢
Alice: What time are we recording the room in the afternoon?
Shure: 还没开始是吗
Shure: Has it not started yet?
Alice:现在收拾一下吧
Alice: Let's tidy up now.
Jake:现在吧
Jake: Now.
其他人：他不是没开始是他平台不支持
Others: It's not that it hasn't started, it's that the platform doesn't support it.
Jake:就是
Jake: Exactly.
Jake:尽快吧
Jake: As soon as possible.
Alice:尽快
Alice: As soon as possible.
Jake:吃完吃完收拾收拾
Jake: Finish eating and tidy up.
Jake:我开始扫
Jake: I'll start sweeping.
Jake:你们在外面待着
Jake: You guys stay outside.
Alice:那我去收拾一下下
Alice: Then I'll go tidy up a bit.
Shure: 可以去航司官网
Shure: You can check on the airline's official website.
其他人：呃 4月30号值机开放
Others: Uh, check-in opens on April 30th.
Lucia: 还要再扫一遍
Lucia: Need to sweep again.
Jake:不要扫
Jake: No need to sweep.
Jake:扫一遍你们装饰之后的就长不一样了
Jake: If you sweep again, it won't look the same after you decorate.
Jake:呵呵呵是吧
Jake: Haha, right?
Alice:找不同
Alice: Spot the difference.
Lucia: 有一些有一些
Lucia: There are some, there are some.
Lucia: 美容值掉下来了
Lucia: The beauty score has dropped.
Lucia: 我再回去粘一下
Lucia: I'll go back and stick it again.
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
Jake:好嘞那我先扫你的
Jake: Okay, I'll clean yours first.
其他人：哎我居然会有南航的常客卡
Others: Wow, I actually have a frequent flyer card with China Southern Airlines.
Jake:先扫你的屋子哦
Jake: I'll clean your room first.
Tasha: 扫啊就现在
Tasha: Clean it now?
Lucia: 你说我粘好之后哦
Lucia: You mean after I stick it?
Tasha: 就是扫装饰完的是吗
Tasha: You mean clean it after decorating, right?
Jake:嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Okay.
Alice:我的也快扫吧因为我那个胶
Alice: Clean mine too because the glue...
Shure: 我很少坐南航的好像
Shure: I rarely fly with China Southern Airlines, I think.
Jake:好好
Jake: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Alice:他老掉对对对
Alice: It keeps falling off, yeah.
Lucia:  我今天早上起来发现他又掉了
Lucia: I woke up this morning and found it fell off again.
Lucia: 那我以为不用了
Lucia: I thought it wasn't needed anymore.
Lucia: 我就没粘
Lucia: So I didn't stick it.
Lucia: 我想在上面粘一下然后再粘
Lucia: I want to stick it up there and then stick it again.
Alice:我全都在粘
Alice: I stick everything.
Jake:那我先扫二楼
Jake: I'll clean the second floor first.
Jake:我先扫你的屋子
Jake: I'll clean your room first.
Shure: 这是什么
Shure: What's this?
Jake:然后你的屋子
Jake: Then your room.
Shure: 我感觉这个比比这个好用很多
Shure: I feel like this is much better than that.
Jake:二楼就
Jake: The second floor...
Jake:我在二楼的时候你们就在一楼待着
Jake: When I'm on the second floor, you guys stay on the first floor.
Shure: 这个APP航旅员就专门的机票的
Shure: This app, Airline Traveler, is specifically for flight tickets.
Jake:然后你可以在一楼再贴一贴
Jake: Then you can stick it again on the first floor.
其他人：航旅员就专门的机票的
Others: Airline Traveler is specifically for flight tickets.
Jake:我下来的时候你就上去
Jake: When I come down, you go up.
Alice:可以可以
Alice: Sure, sure.
Jake:就这么回事
Jake: That's how it works.
Alice:在院子应该也行都一样
Alice: It should be fine in the yard too, all the same.
Shure: 完了我out了
Shure: Oh no, I'm out.
其他人：不常坐吧
Others: You don't fly often, right?
其他人：哎呦少爷
Others: Oh, young master.
其他人：订机票还需要自己订吗
Others: Do you even need to book your own tickets?
其他人：所以就当然不知道了
Others: So of course, you wouldn't know.
Shure: 你滚呵呵呵呵
Shure: Get lost, hahaha.
Shure: 阴阳怪气谁呢
Shure: Who are you being sarcastic to?
其他人：谁接了阴阳怪气谁呢
Others: Who took that sarcastic tone?
Jake:哼哼你倒一点
Jake: Hmph, pour a little.
Lucia: 你给我倒点
Lucia: Pour me some.
Shure: 我操
Shure: Damn it.
Lucia: 我给你拿点别的
Lucia: I'll get you something else.
Shure: 可以可以
Shure: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 哈哈应该还有别的吗
Lucia: Haha, there should be something else, right?
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Jake:哦到位了
Jake: Oh, it's perfect.
其他人：特别喜欢特别喜欢
Others: Really like it, really like it.
其他人：选前舱就是因为可以可以最后上飞机
Others: Chose the front cabin because we can be the last to board the plane.
Jake:挺好走一遍流程
Jake: It's nice to go through the process.
Tasha: 走一遍流程
Tasha: Go through the process.
其他人：然后最早下去
Others: And then get off first.
其他人：这个飞机好大
Others: This plane is huge.
其他人：这个飞机同同一排九
Others: This plane, nine seats in a row.
Lucia: 我去看看还有啥喝的给你拿一点
Lucia: I'll go see what else there is to drink and get you something.
Shure: 我应该给他允许
Shure: I should allow him.
Jake:哼哼找找
Jake: Hmph, look around.
Jake:喝吗
Jake: Drink?
Jake:喝水里面有可乐喝
Jake: Drink, there's cola in the water.
其他人：加一下绑一下身份证
Others: Add it, link the ID.
Shure: 咱俩去杭州的那个高铁是不还没买
Shure: Did we buy the high-speed train tickets to Hangzhou yet?
其他人：是的
Others: No.
Shure: 那个着急吗
Shure: Is it urgent?
其他人：我也不知道
Others: I don't know either.
Shure: 嗯哎
Shure: Hmm, hey.
其他人：我白鹿的城市卡是
Others: My White Deer city card is...
其他人：这张卡的卡号是什么啊
Others: What's the number on this card?
其他人：南航厦航对
Others: China Southern, Xiamen Airlines, right.
Shure: 哎我绑过了
Shure: Hey, I've linked it.
Shure: 但他为什么没有
Shure: But why doesn't it show?
其他人：什么没有
Others: What doesn't show?
其他人：不是订单啊
Others: Not the order?
Shure: 我的行程哦
Shure: My itinerary, oh.
Shure: 神奇
Shure: Strange.
Shure: 四驱航空
Shure: Four-wheel drive airline.
Shure: 中国国航AR China
Shure: Air China, AR China.
Lucia: 我的灯还亮着吗
Lucia: Is my light still on?
Jake:不亮了
Jake: It's off.
Lucia: 我刚突然反应过来
Lucia: I just suddenly realized.
Shure: 我的灯应该亮着吧
Shure: My light should be on, right?
Lucia: 我好像我把线拿了下来
Lucia: I think I took the cable off.
Lucia: 但是没有接上
Lucia: But didn't plug it in.
Jake:哦充电宝那边有很多哦
Jake: Oh, there are many power banks over there.
Lucia: 没事充电宝在这哦
Lucia: It's okay, the power bank is here.
Jake:哈哈哈你的任务太多了
Jake: Haha, you have too many tasks.
Lucia: 处理的任务太多了
Lucia: 我现在把这个关了
Lucia: I'll turn this off now.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
其他人：天府到南宁到大兴
Others: From Tianfu to Nanning to Daxing.
其他人：拉萨哎我为什么有这么多
Others: Lhasa, why do I have so many?
其他人：哦还有个南充的
Others: Oh, there's also one from Nanchong.
Jake:先倒点桃汁
Jake: Pour some peach juice first.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:请能来个新的吧
Jake: Can we get a new one, please?
Shure: 真没消停
Shure: Never a moment of peace.
Jake:咱不差杯子
Jake: We don't lack cups.
Shure: 玩累了是吗
Shure: Tired of playing?
Lucia: 我先把这个看下
Lucia: Let me check this first.
Shure: 公主
Shure: Princess.
其他人：他这个倒很多
Others: He poured a lot.
Jake:喝吗
Jake: Drink it?
Jake:他他好像都没有喝
Jake: He seems like he didn't even drink.
Jake:你喝吗这些东西
Jake: Do you drink these things?
Katrina: 我喝矿泉水
Katrina: I drink mineral water.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 嗯嗯啊嗯
Shure: Mhm, mhm, ah, mhm.
Shure: 因为我来北京什么的
Shure: Because I came to Beijing and stuff.
Jake:喝吗
Jake: Drink it?
Alice:我手机在这吗
Alice: Is my phone here?
Shure: 剩下也不用
Shure: Don't need the rest.
Shure: 那什么他这个能查到多多少啊
Shure: So, how much can he check from this?
Lucia: 好像没有啊
Lucia: Seems like no.
Jake:没看着
Jake: Didn't see it.
Shure: 更多的话
Shure: More of it.
其他人：我这直接到13年了
Others: Mine goes directly to 2013.
Shure: 那我到不了
Shure: I can't get there.
Shure: 我搁前面肯定更有啊
Shure: If I were in front, I'd definitely have more.
Shure: 去解锁哎呀
Shure: Go unlock it, oh man.
Shure: 还要会员
Shure: Need a membership too.
Shure: 我去你
Shure: Oh come on.
其他人：没用啊
Others: It's useless.
其他人：我历史行程没用啊
Others: My travel history is useless.
Shure: 那可能从那时候就开始有了
Shure: Maybe it started from then.
Shure: 我要看看有没有乱飞
Shure: I need to check if there's any random flights.
其他人：乱飞在这里乱飞
Others: Random flights here, random flights.
Shure: 优惠券我找一找
Shure: Let me find the coupons.
其他人：大洲两个国家
Others: Two countries on the continent.
其他人： 两个三个两个
Others: Two or three, two.
其他人：哼飞行最多东营到北京
Others: The most flights from Dongying to Beijing.
Jake:你们一半的饭
Jake: Half of your food.
Jake:只吃一半
Jake: Just eat half.
Jake:一半的一半是吧
Jake: Half of the half, right?
Jake:嗯这你就是健胃超市便
Jake: Yeah, this is just like a digestive aid.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Katrina: 哦就你就是健胃消食片
Katrina: Oh, it's like a digestive tablet.
Shure: 我们两个
Shure: The two of us.
Shure: 我们两个都吃完了
Shure: We both finished.
Shure: 我们是不是对我还
Shure: We, right? I also...
Jake:加上了两个健胃消食片
Jake: Added two digestive tablets.
Shure: 我还加餐两个健胃消食片呢
Shure: I also added two more digestive tablets.
Jake:对嗯
Jake: Yeah.
其他人： 超过全国用户81.28%
Others: Exceeded 81.28% of users nationwide.
其他人：看出来前几年没怎么出去玩了
Others: Looks like you didn't go out much the past few years.
其他人：你看18 对
Others: Look, 18 right?
其他人：在上高中完全没有出门
Others: In high school, didn't go out at all.
Shure: 杭州飞长春
Shure: Hangzhou to Changchun flight.
Jake:这啥呀这是
Jake: What's this?
Lucia: 洋葱
Lucia: Onion.
其他人：好远
Others: So far.
Jake:炒洋葱是吧
Jake: Fried onions, right?
其他人：这趟真的就
Others: This trip really...
Jake:嗯这道菜
Jake: Yeah, this dish.
Lucia: 然后还有回锅肉
Lucia: And then there's twice-cooked pork.
其他人：哎我居然
Others: Oh, I actually...
Jake:回锅肉没有找到了
Jake: Couldn't find the twice-cooked pork.
其他人：起飞降落都是在
Others: Both takeoff and landing are...
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 嗨
Katrina: Hi.
Katrina: 你在哪呢
Katrina: Where are you?
其他人：乱七八糟
Others: So messy.
Katrina: 你搁哪呢
Katrina: Where are you?
Katrina: 在新家
Katrina: At the new house.
Katrina: 你看昨天给你拍照片
Katrina: Did you see the photos I sent you yesterday?
Shure: 切
Shure: Pfft.
Shure: 无聊
Shure: Boring.
Katrina: 我这说话不利索
Katrina: I'm not speaking clearly.
Katrina: 呵呵我说昨天给你发的照片看了不
Katrina: Haha, did you see the photos I sent you yesterday?
Shure: 没醒酒的吧
Shure: Are you still hungover?
其他人：就飞的超级多
Others: There were so many flights.
Katrina: 然后我没发吗
Katrina: Didn't I send them?
Katrina: 他们装扮的都好好看
Katrina: They all dressed up so nicely.
Katrina: 我以后也要搞成这个样子
Katrina: I want to dress like that in the future.
其他人：沈阳
Others: Shenyang.
其他人：长春
Others: Changchun.
Shure: 呦还来过长春哎呀
Shure: Oh, you've been to Changchun too?
Katrina: 我明天早上把我买的一些东西寄回去
Katrina: I'll send back some things I bought tomorrow morning.
Katrina: 啊上次买的那衣服寄到家了吗
Katrina: Did the clothes I bought last time arrive at home?
其他人：济南广西云南四川
Others: Jinan, Guangxi, Yunnan, Sichuan.
其他人：四川飞的也多
Others: Many flights to Sichuan too.
Katrina: 哦上次
Katrina: Oh, last time...
Katrina: 你知道那两大坨寄快递好多钱吗
Katrina: Do you know how much it cost to send those two big packages?
其他人：四川主要年年去哎
Others: We go to Sichuan every year.
其他人：这是飞哪
Others: Where's this flight to?
其他人：飞南充啊
Others: To Nanchong.
Katrina: 对啊我跟你说过了
Katrina: Yeah, I told you.
其他人：然后两趟拉萨
Others: And then two trips to Lhasa.
Katrina: 原来超便宜
Katrina: It used to be super cheap.
其他人：嗯
Others: Mm.
Katrina: 今天22号
Katrina: Today is the 22nd.
其他人：没怎么出去玩可惜
Others: It's a shame we didn't go out much.
Katrina: 今天休息一天
Katrina: Taking a day off today.
Shure: 没怎么出去玩
Shure: Didn't go out much.
Shure: 那我是什么
Shure: So what am I?
Shure: 没怎么活着是吗
Shure: Barely living?
Jake:今天你们不在干活吗
Jake: Aren't you guys working today?
Katrina: 我们戴眼镜就是干活
Katrina: We're working, just wearing glasses.
Katrina: 嗯吃回锅肉
Katrina: Hmm, eating twice-cooked pork.
Jake:现在你妈妈也在干活
Jake: Now your mom is also working.
Katrina: 我爹呢
Katrina: What about my dad?
其他人：往合肥定了好几趟 10月3号
Others: We've booked several trips to Hefei for October 3rd.
Lucia: 我觉得只要出境的人都在干活
Lucia: I think everyone who goes abroad is working.
其他人：本来打算10月一回家然后
Others: Originally planned to go home on October 1st, then...
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Jake:嗯确实确实
Jake: Yeah, definitely.
Katrina: 我爹在装空调
Katrina: My dad is installing an air conditioner.
Lucia: 全民大工作呵呵
Lucia: Everyone's working hard, haha.
其他人：先回趟家
Others: Let's go home first.
Lucia: 那个大学习全身是什么
Lucia: What is this "Great Study"?
Katrina: 这白的是什么
Katrina: What's this white thing?
Katrina: 这是冰箱吗
Katrina: Is this a fridge?
其他人：1,600
Others: 1,600.
Shure:  我300
Shure: I have 300.
Katrina: 这个卡其色是什么东西啊
Katrina: What's this khaki thing?
其他人：你想退票
Others: You want to refund the ticket?
其他人：退票手续费还有那么多
Others: The refund fee is still quite high.
Lucia: 青年大学习
Lucia: Youth Study.
Shure: 啧啧啧
Shure: Tsk tsk tsk.
Shure: 富婆
Shure: Rich lady.
其他人：哦这个是直接飞富阳了
Others: Oh, this one flies directly to Fuyang.
Jake:没有哪个
Jake: Not that one.
其他人：飞富阳便宜
Others: Flying to Fuyang is cheaper.
Katrina: 看不清啊
Katrina: Can't see clearly.
Jake:亲现在哦
Jake: Look now, oh.
Katrina: 这啥颜色啊
Katrina: What color is this?
Shure: 是的但是其实我上学
Shure: Yes, but actually when I was in school...
Lucia: OK但是其实我上学那会
Lucia: OK, but actually when I was in school...
Lucia: 就是我认识的别的学校同学都有的
Lucia: The students I knew from other schools all had it.
其他人：那干嘛
Others: Then why...
Katrina: 都行啊都行啊
Katrina: It's all good, it's all good.
其他人：看看我刘海
Others: Look at my bangs.
其他人：长了是吗嗯
Others: They grew, right? Hmm.
Katrina: 现在我已经会装饰我的房间了
Katrina: Now I can already decorate my room.
Lucia: 以现就不太熟
Lucia: So now I'm not that familiar.
Shure: 好困
Shure: So sleepy.
Lucia:  我为什么会觉得他叫全民大学习呢
Lucia: Why do I feel like it's called "Great Study for All"?
Katrina: 可以啊
Katrina: Sure.
Jake:确实结论上是全民大学习
Jake: Indeed, the conclusion is a nationwide study.
Shure: 为什么
Shure: Why?
Shure: 哎不是
Shure: Hey, wait.
Shure: 那我就去看一下
Shure: Let me go check it out.
Shure: 我现在卧槽
Shure: Oh crap.
Katrina: 可以啊你搞绿色就行
Katrina: Sure, just go with green.
Katrina: 反正我买的东西都是绿色系
Katrina: Anyway, everything I bought is green.
Shure: 真服了
Shure: I'm really impressed.
其他人：那你在火车退票
Others: Then you can cancel the train ticket.
其他人：那不也挺好的
Others: Isn't that good too?
Katrina: 好的好的没问题
Katrina: Alright, alright, no problem.
Shure: 5%的话的话没多少钱吧
Shure: If it's 5%, it's not much money, right?
Katrina: （歌词）没有你在我有多难熬
Katrina: (singing) It's so hard without you around.
Shure: 525呗
Shure: 525, right?
Lucia: 我们虽然没有那个青年大学习
Lucia: Even though we don't have that youth study program,
Shure: 五六三十
Shure: Five, six, thirty.
Lucia: 但我们有语课堂
Lucia: But we have language classes.
Katrina: 收拾收拾房间
Katrina: Clean up the room.
其他人：二十块
Others: Twenty bucks.
Katrina: 洗洗碗睡睡觉
Katrina: Wash the dishes, take a nap.
Lucia: 就是怎么形容它有点像Cosera
Lucia: It's kind of like Coursera, I guess.
Shure: 对 20多不到30
Shure: Yeah, over 20 but less than 30.
Shure: 嗯嗯
Shure: Mm-hmm.
Katrina: 是要收拾收拾东西
Katrina: I need to tidy up my stuff.
Shure: 我这怎么用啊
Shure: How do I use this?
Shure: 我真的不会用这个
Shure: I really don't know how to use this.
其他人：我我其实不太用它
Others: I actually don't use it much.
其他人：买机票我会用它
Others: I use it for booking flights.
其他人：就是看信息
Others: Just to check information.
Katrina: 是啊回去写毕社了都
Katrina: Yeah, going back to write my thesis.
Katrina: 不习惯了都
Katrina: I'm not used to it anymore.
其他人：它机场大屏
Others: It has a big screen at the airport.
其他人：然后值机什么都能在这里
Others: And you can check in and everything here.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 毕业还是没问题
Katrina: Graduation is not a problem.
Katrina: 能毕业这么呵呵
Katrina: We can graduate, haha.
Shure: 我看看
Shure: Let me see.
Shure: 为什么你就能买到那么便宜的
Shure: How come you can get it so cheap?
Shure: 为什么不是平衡的
Shure: Why isn't it balanced?
其他人：因为他是那种波动的
Others: Because it's volatile.
Lucia: 我们在这生物
Lucia: We're in this biology...
Shure: 不理解
Shure: I don't understand.
Katrina: 肯定能毕业的呀
Katrina: We'll definitely graduate.
Jake:哈哈哈就学这些东西
Jake: Hahaha, just studying these things.
Shure: 很烦
Shure: It's so annoying.
Lucia: 对我们还学这个
Lucia: Yeah, we even study this.
Lucia: 没想到
Lucia: Didn't expect that.
Jake:没想到
Jake: Didn't expect that.
Katrina: 这我爹吗
Katrina: Is this my dad?
Lucia: 然后这个课也有
Lucia: And this class too.
Shure: 你这种叫时时蹲点是吗
Shure: Is this what you call constant monitoring?
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
其他人：没有啊运气好而已
Others: No, it's just luck.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我爹这头好搞笑
Katrina: Hahaha, my dad's head looks so funny.
Shure: 什么好运都让你赶上了
Shure: You always get all the good luck.
Jake:我们北游的课比较离谱的
Jake: Our Northern University's courses are quite outrageous.
Jake:就是所有的学科都要学
Jake: We have to study every subject.
其他人：计划登机7:20
Others: Scheduled boarding at 7:20.
Jake:学傅里叶变换
Jake: Learning Fourier Transform.
Jake:傅里叶变换就学日语学
Jake: Learning Fourier Transform as well as Japanese.
其他人：我6点出门吗
Others: Should I leave at 6?
Shure: 得出了
Shure: You should.
Jake:学俄语也要学复利页变换
Jake: Learning Russian means learning Fourier Transform too.
其他人：6点出门我要前天
Others: If I leave at 6, I'll be there the day before.
Lucia: 为什么呀
Lucia: Why?
其他人：我住那附近吗
Others: I live nearby, right?
Lucia: 用不到啊
Lucia: It's not necessary.
Jake:就是嘿嘿
Jake: Exactly, hehe.
其他人：我住机场旁边
Others: I live next to the airport.
Jake:可能翻译著作吧
Jake: Maybe it's for translating works.
其他人：应该可以吧
Others: Should be fine.
Shure:  那你要
Shure: Then you need to...
Lucia: 翻译
Lucia: Translate.
Lucia: 翻译数学著作吗
Lucia: Translate math works?
Shure: 大兴
Shure: Daxing.
Jake:呃同性原理
Jake: Uh, the principle of homogeneity.
Jake:同性的东西
Jake: Homogeneous stuff.
Shure: 你有北里良乡的朋友吗
Shure: Do you have friends in Beiliang Township?
Lucia: 统计学呀
Lucia: Statistics.
Shure: 那你去的话帮我啊
Shure: If you go, help me out, okay?
Shure: 明天我可以跟你一起去
Shure: I can go with you tomorrow.
其他人：你为什么明天可以跟我一起去
Others: Why can you go with me tomorrow?
Lucia: 我学盖桶的时候学的不太好
Lucia: I didn't learn well when I was learning to cover the bucket.
Lucia: 但是学那个ignometrics
Lucia: But I learned ignometrics.
Shure: 我明天要上班
Shure: I have to work tomorrow.
Katrina: 我爹叼都不叼我一眼呢
Katrina: My dad doesn't even look at me.
Shure: 可以先去
Shure: We can go first.
Shure: 然后我之后去上班
Shure: Then I'll go to work afterward.
Lucia: 你看我其实英文没有变好
Lucia: You see, my English hasn't improved.
其他人：对 9点钟
Others: Yeah, at 9 o'clock.
Lucia: 但是中文变差了
Lucia: But my Chinese has gotten worse.
Katrina: 忙吧
Katrina: Busy, huh?
Jake:我今天哈哈哈哈
Jake: Today, hahaha.
Katrina: 忙点好
Katrina: Being busy is good.
其他人：9点还是九点半
Others: 9 or 9:30?
Jake:没英文英文变好了
Jake: No, my English has improved.
其他人：忘了上次去怎么说
Others: Forgot how to say it last time.
Jake:英文好了
Jake: My English is better now.
Lucia: 速度完全赶不上我的同学
Lucia: I can't keep up with my classmates' speed at all.
Shure: 九点开门
Shure: Opens at 9 o'clock.
Shure: 反正我要想去给你妹妹买个手串
Shure: Anyway, I want to get a bracelet for your sister.
Jake:哈哈哈没关系
Jake: Hahaha, it's okay.
其他人：给你妹妹买个手串
Others: Get a bracelet for your sister.
Jake:混着说
Jake: Speak mixed.
其他人：总得带点东西
Others: You have to bring something.
Lucia: 然后学那个计量的时候
Lucia: And then when learning metrics.
其他人：你不要你不要用那种
Others: Don't use that kind of...
Lucia: 因为很多东西概统学过一次
Lucia: Because a lot of things were learned once.
Shure: 不是我妈让我去干这个去
Shure: It's not that my mom asked me to do this.
Lucia: 嗯然后于是就突然学了很多
Lucia: Hmm, and then I suddenly learned a lot.
Katrina: 咱还有水果吃吗
Katrina: Do we still have fruit to eat?
Shure: 他妈的
Shure: Damn it.
Jake:有水果汁
Jake: There's fruit juice.
Katrina: 嗯哈哈哈
Katrina: Hmm, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 没事那就说你买的
Shure: It's okay, just say you bought it.
Katrina: 这是什么水果哈
Katrina: What kind of fruit is this?
Jake:这什么水果
Jake: What kind of fruit is this?
Jake:双鸭三鸭这是
Jake: Double duck, triple duck, this is.
其他人：给我一拳吧
Others: Give me a punch.
其他人：我受不了
Others: I can't take it anymore.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哎呀
Jake: Hahaha, oh man.
Lucia: AI能反应过来吗
Lucia: Can AI react to this?
Shure: 那你去吧
Shure: Then you go ahead.
Shure: 这任务就交给你了
Shure: This task is all yours.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahaha.
Shure: 他嫂子哈哈哈哈
Shure: His sister-in-law, hahahaha.
Lucia: 这要说话带口音的话怎么办呀
Lucia: What if we speak with an accent?
Lucia: 只和吃的好
Lucia: Only good with food.
Shure: 明天是初几啊
Shure: What's the date tomorrow?
Katrina: 给你点赞
Katrina: Thumbs up for you.
Jake:嗯哼哼差别不大
Jake: Mhm, not much difference.
Shure: 明天是15
Shure: Tomorrow is the 15th.
其他人：我看的明天是15
Others: I think tomorrow is the 15th.
其他人：哎呀我真烦你们
Others: Ugh, you guys really annoy me.
Shure: 那你去呗
Shure: Then you go.
Shure: 我又不是没让你
Shure: I didn't stop you.
Shure: 那你买了不就不用我买了吗
Shure: If you buy it, I don't have to.
Lucia: 我小时候我妈给我讲过一个笑话是嗯
Lucia: When I was little, my mom told me a joke...
Shure: 多好啊好看好看啊
Shure: It's great, looks good.
Katrina: 好看好看
Katrina: Looks good.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mhm.
其他人：哼生气
Others: Hmph, I'm angry.
Lucia: 就陕西话里面就是头
Lucia: In Shaanxi dialect, "head" means...
Katrina: 好看很高级
Katrina: Looks good, very classy.
Shure: 这生什么气啊生气
Shure: Why are you angry?
Jake:嗯就是
Jake: Exactly.
Lucia: 如果是很很很传统的方言是头这个词
Lucia: If it's a very traditional dialect, "head" means...
Shure: 你买对的就行
Shure: Just buy the right one.
Katrina: 好看你自己开心就好
Katrina: As long as you're happy.
Shure: 别给我妹求成姻缘了就行哈哈哈
Shure: Just don't ask for a matchmaker for my sister, haha.
Katrina: 你自己的钱
Katrina: It's your own money.
Jake:这是啥对这是
Jake: What is this exactly?
Lucia: 这是啥这是
Lucia: What is this?
Jake:哈哈哈哈他确实不知道这是啥对吧
Jake: Hahaha, he really doesn't know what this is, right?
其他人：对对对阿姨让你买
Others: Yeah, yeah, Auntie asked you to buy it.
其他人：求求求什么
Others: Ask for what exactly?
Katrina: 把我们家搞成五星级酒店了
Katrina: Turned our home into a five-star hotel.
Shure: 你猜猜呢
Shure: What do you think?
Shure: 他这么大还能求什么
Shure: What could he still wish for at his age?
Lucia: 摇头脑对吧
Lucia: Shaking heads, right?
其他人：求平安还是求学业
Others: Wishing for peace or academic success.
Jake:嗯对啊
Jake: Yeah, that's right.
Lucia: 不知道为啥
Shure: 求学业
Shure: Wishing for academic success.
Jake:他为什么叫撒
Jake: Why does he say that?
Shure: 交给你了
Shure: It's up to you.
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: No idea.
Jake:一般会怎么用呢
Jake: How do people generally use it?
Jake:就是我我撒上有个撒
Jake: Like, I have a thing with this thing.
Katrina: 哇塞这么
Katrina: Wow, that's...
其他人： 好不容易做了计划
Others: Finally made a plan.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 所以有一个笑话
Lucia: So there's this joke.
其他人：结果气死我了
Others: In the end, it made me so mad.
Lucia: 就是有一个陕西人走进医院
Lucia: So there's this guy from Shaanxi who walks into a hospital.
Shure: 没有我
Shure: Not me.
Shure: 我说我上班去然后他嫂子帮他买的
Shure: I said I was going to work, then his sister-in-law bought it for him.
Lucia:   然后医生说你撒疼我怎么能知道呢
Lucia: And then the doctor says, "How should I know where it hurts?"
Shure: 多好
Shure: How nice.
Shure: 不要啊
Shure: No, don't.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 哈哈没事没事
Shure: Haha, it's fine, it's fine.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm.
Shure: 哎你忘掉我刚刚没有跟你说过
Shure: Hey, just forget it, I didn't tell you that.
Shure: 然后我说我说我要去买
Shure: And then I said I was going to buy it.
Shure: 他说哎我正好买了
Shure: He said, "Hey, I just bought it."
Jake:对哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah, hahaha.
Shure: 哎你别气你别气
Shure: Hey, don't be mad, don't be mad.
Lucia: 就是平常都说普通话
Lucia: We usually speak Mandarin.
Lucia: 但是我觉得我感觉啊
Lucia: But I feel like, I think...
Shure: 我回去待会回去待会
Shure: I'll go back, I'll go back in a bit.
Lucia: 就即使你是陕西有时候也反应不过来
Lucia: Even if you're from Shaanxi, sometimes you can't keep up.
Lucia: 我会这么觉得啊
Lucia: That's how I feel.
Shure: 进屋待会
Shure: I'll go inside for a bit.
Katrina: 好看
Katrina: Looks good.
Shure: 进屋待会
Shure: I'll go inside for a bit.
Jake:当然可能人家如果
Jake: Of course, if someone...
Katrina: 有点像阿姨家的风格
Katrina: It kind of has an auntie's style.
Jake:就是一直语言环境都这样啥
Jake: The language environment has always been like this.
Jake:应该是东北东北话
Jake: It should be the Northeastern dialect.
Jake:然后以前陕西那边没什么东北人
Jake: And there weren't many Northeasterners in Shaanxi before.
Jake:就还没还好
Jake: So it was okay.
Jake:哈哈是吧东北就是不去陕西
Jake: Haha, right? Northeasterners just don't go to Shaanxi.
Lucia: 没什么东北
Lucia: There weren't many Northeasterners.
Shure: 我们东北人又怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with us Northeasterners?
Jake:因为陕西里边他们把头叫啥
Jake: Because in Shaanxi, what do they call the head?
Lucia: 啥就是最最最传统陕西方言的话
Lucia: What, in the most traditional Shaanxi dialect?
Katrina: 好看内好看内
Katrina: It's so pretty, so pretty.
Jake:就是因为这个
Jake: It's because of this.
Lucia: 就是这是啥
Lucia: What is this?
Jake:就是这是啥
Jake: What is this?
Shure: 呵呵呵呵呵
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 太烂了这谐音梗
Shure: This pun is so bad.
Shure: 我受不了了
Shure: I can't take it.
Jake:这是啥
Jake: What is this?
Alice:靠这个碗都粘不到1块了
Alice: This bowl isn't even worth a dollar.
Alice:哇哦
Alice: Wow.
Shure: 吓一跳是吗
Shure: Got scared, right?
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 嘿嘿嘿哦
Shure: Hehehe.
Shure: 眼镜没戴
Shure: Didn't wear my glasses.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 接下来的画面你不能看喽
Shure: You can't watch the next scene.
其他人：神经病
Others: Crazy.
Shure: 困了要睡觉了
Shure: I'm tired, I need to sleep.
Shure: 哦我
Shure: Oh, I...
Shure: 今天早上我没喝咖啡
Shure: I didn't drink coffee this morning.
Shure: 我给你弄得我没喝
Shure: I made it for you and didn't drink it myself.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Shure: 我做完之后
Shure: After I made it,
Shure: 我就下意识以为我自己喝完了
Shure: I subconsciously thought I had already drunk it.
Shure: 知道吗
Shure: You know?
Shure: 我说怎么还这么困呢哈哈哈
Shure: I was wondering why I was still so tired, hahaha.
其他人：笑死了
Others: That's hilarious.
其他人： 气死我了气死我了没事
Others: I'm so mad, I'm so mad, it's okay.
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's okay.
其他人：生闷气
Others: Sulking.
Shure: 挺好的挺好的挺好的
Shure: It's all good, it's all good.
其他人：挺好的，这能一样吗
Others: How can this be the same?
Shure: 就跟
Shure: Just like...
其他人：你不一样
Others: You're not the same.
Shure: 你问我想要什么生日礼物
Shure: You asked me what I wanted for my birthday.
Shure: 其实原理是一样的
Shure: Actually, the principle is the same.
Shure: 正好他现在非常好
Shure: And now he's just fine.
其他人：但不一样哎呀
Others: But it's not the same, oh come on.
其他人：呜呜呜呜呜呜呜呜
Shure: 我不应该跟你说的是吧
Shure: Should I not have told you?
其他人：你不是不应不你
Others: No, you should've.
其他人：你其实应该跟我说的
Others: You really should have told me.
其他人：但是这两个就不是一个性质了
Others: But these two things are not the same.
其他人：你知道吗
Others: You know?
Shure: 我觉得好像你在帮忙代购一样
Shure: I feel like you're doing a shopping service for me.
Shure: 和你自己准备的一个感觉一样
Shure: Feels the same as if you prepared it yourself.
Shure: 是是这个感觉是吗
Shure: Is that how it feels?
其他人：呜呜呜呜呜呜
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
其他人：气死我了气死我了
Others: I'm so angry.
Shure: 没有关系没有关系
Shure: It's okay, it's okay.
其他人：有关系
Others: It matters.
其他人：其实还是应该在
Others: Actually, it should still be...
其他人：在有这个想法时就跟你说
Others: You should've told me when you first had the idea.
其他人：然后说不定能赶赶到了
Others: Maybe we could've made it in time.
Shure: 然后他说我要去的话
Shure: And then he said if I want to go...
Shure: 我本来是打算25号去
Shure: I was planning to go on the 25th.
其他人：说不定能赶到阿姨说之前
Others: Maybe we could've made it before Auntie said.
其他人：然后你就可以
Others: And then you could...
其他人：哦真的吗
Others: Oh really?
其他人：啊正好那个你现在哈哈哈
Others: Ah, just right, now you're... hahaha.
Shure: 哦我这样
Shure: Oh, like this.
Shure: 我先给我妈打电话说妈不用我去了
Shure: I'll call my mom and say, "Mom, I don't need to go."
Shure: 她买完了居然
Shure: She actually bought it already.
Shure: 好刻意啊
Shure: It's so deliberate.
Shure: 没事没事我给你妈你圆回去好不好
Shure: It's okay, it's okay, I'll talk to your mom and smooth it over, okay?
Shure: 啊这样我25号说哎妈我要去
Shure: Ah, so on the 25th I'll say, "Hey mom, I want to go."
Shure: 然后我问他然后他问他奥特居然买了
Shure: Then I asked him and he asked, and she actually bought it already.
其他人：所以为什么25号
Others: So why the 25th?
其他人：我24号我就不在北京了
Others: I'm not going to be in Beijing on the 24th.
其他人：阿姨不是也知道我要去上海吗
Others: Auntie knows I'm going to Shanghai, right?
其他人：他知道我比你早走几天
Others: She knows I'm leaving a few days earlier than you.
Shure: 吗那我不知道
Shure: Well, I didn't know that.
其他人：完了又解释不清了
Others: Great, now it's hard to explain again.
其他人：又这么带着你全国瞎转悠了
Others: You've been wandering around the whole country again.
其他人：不行你现在给我圆
Others: No, you need to fix this now.
其他人：你快去你快给我圆
Others: Hurry up, you need to fix this.
Shure: 我肯定给你圆
Shure: I'll definitely fix it for you.
Shure: 你现在现在
Shure: You, now, now.
Shure: 我原计划是1525号去然后我25号去
Shure: My original plan was to go on the 15th or the 25th, then I went on the 25th.
Shure: 之前说快告诉我
Shure: You said earlier, tell me quickly.
其他人：你25号 你会忘记这件事情吗
Others: The 25th, will you forget about this?
Shure: 不行你现在你现在
Shure: No, you now, you now.
Shure: 哈哈哈不不不明天
Shure: Haha, no no no, tomorrow.
Shure: 明天我就正常上班
Shure: Tomorrow I'll just go to work as usual.
Shure: 然后我上班
Shure: Then I'll go to work.
Shure: 然后你给我发
Shure: Then you send me.
Shure: 照片然后说给妹妹带
Shure: The photo, then say it's for my sister.
Shure: 然后我跟我妈说哎
Shure: Then I'll tell my mom, hey.
Shure: 她正好给妹妹带了不用我去
Shure: She brought it for my sister, so I don't need to go.
Shure: 大概就这么冤枉我了
Shure: That's basically how I got blamed.
其他人：真讨厌啊可以吧
Others: Really annoying, isn't it?
其他人：讨厌
Others: Annoying.
Shure: 你别撞枪口上
Shure: Don't put yourself in the line of fire.
Shure: 那没办法
Shure: There's no other way.
Shure: 这我之前跟你说过这个事情
Shure: I told you about this before.
其他人：你什么时候跟我说过
Others: When did you tell me?
Shure: 我忘了咱俩那次在哪来着
Shure: I forgot, where were we that time?
Shure: 我还问你就是阴历几阴历几
Shure: I even asked you what day of the lunar calendar it was.
Shure: 我说我想去雍和宫请手串
Shure: 然后你还说出去出不去
Shure: And you said whether we could go out or not.
其他人：我也不知道你是要去请什么串呀
Others: I didn't know what kebabs you were getting.
Shure: 现在你知道了吧
Shure: Now you know, right?
其他人：哎不是
Others: Hey, wait.
其他人：这怎么还有一根啊
Others: Why is there another one?
Shure: 是的你不止一根
Shure: Yes, you have more than one.
Shure: 你脑袋现在大概三根白头发
Shure: You probably have three white hairs now.
其他人：哦不是吓死我了
Others: Oh, it scared me.
其他人：这是我那个头发
Others: It's my hair.
其他人：那个染的那个头发
Others: The dyed hair.
其他人：我说怎么会在这个地方呢
Others: I was wondering why it was here.
其他人：还剩这么点点
Others: There's so little left.
其他人：那就找了
Others: Then let's find it.
Shure: 第二天首先洗一下啊
Shure: First thing in the morning, let's wash up.
Shure: 大群消息
Shure: A lot of messages.
Shure: 毕设
Shure: 我要做毕设
其他人：好生气啊
Others: So angry!
其他人：你快圆一下
Others: Quickly fix this.
其他人：现在
Others: Now.
其他人：讨厌
Others: Annoying.
其他人：你真讨厌
其他人：讨厌讨厌讨厌讨厌讨厌讨厌
Others: Annoying, annoying, annoying.
Shure: 我咋了啊
Shure: 我说你怎么突然想娶我呢
其他人：讨厌
Shure: 挺好的吗
其他人：转我20 我下去买彩票去
Others: Transfer me 20, I'm going to buy a lottery ticket.
其他人：预算哈哈哈
Shure: 20都得先预支着吧
Shure: Even 20 needs to be budgeted.
Shure: 现在咱俩的感情吧
Shure: Our relationship now...
Shure: 生分到这种程度
Shure: has become so distant.
Shure: 别躺我身上了
Shure: Stop lying on me.
其他人：没躺你身上啊
Others: I'm not lying on you.
其他人：躺被子上呢
Others: I'm on the blanket.
其他人：谁啊摸我干什么臭流氓
Others: Who's touching me? What a pervert!
其他人：哎呀气死我了
Others: Oh my, I'm so mad.
Shure: 哎呀别气
Shure: 我给你转20
其他人：这他其实也不是气
Others: Actually, it's not anger.
其他人：就是哈哈哈
Others: It's just, haha.
其他人：难受难受
Others: It's uncomfortable.
其他人：你天天还说我看病没品
Others: You always say I'm rude when I'm sick.
其他人：你这不是也没品
Others: You're also rude.
其他人：真地狱啊
Others: It's hell.
其他人：阎王换届都得考虑一下你
Others: Even the king of hell would consider you.
Shure: 阎王换届吗
Shure: The king of hell is changing?
其他人：换吧
Shure: 那不是挺好
其他人：你怎么知道
Others: How do you know?
其他人：人现在也得有考核标准了
Others: People need evaluation standards now.
Shure: 是吗哈哈
Shure: Really? Haha.
Shure: 那明天你小心点
Shure: Be careful tomorrow.
其他人：这附近有彩票站吗
Shure: 真有，我们那回去买了
其他人：走现在去
Others: Go now.
其他人：真的真的
Others: Really, really.
其他人：换下衣服不能穿也睡衣
Others: Change clothes, you can't wear pajamas.
其他人：哪边是正面哪边是反面
Others: Which side is the front, which side is the back?
其他人：真真真真真
Others: Really, really, really, really.
其他人：中大奖了怎么办
Others: What if we win the lottery?
Shure: 真中不会不给我吧
Shure: If we win, you won't give me nothing, right?
其他人：我我收一半的
Others: I'll keep half.
Shure: 那赔的呢
Shure: What about the losses?
Shure: 赔的就都算我的对
Shure: All the losses are on me, right?
Shure: 我能怎么办呢
Shure: What can I do?
Shure: 礼物的哎呦我去哈哈哈
Shure: A gift, oh my gosh, hahaha
其他人：对不起对不起
Others: Sorry, sorry
Shure: 真是人啊你
Shure: You are really something, you know that?
Shure: 不管我死活真以为这家就咱俩是吧
Shure: You don't care about me at all, you really think it's just the two of us in this house, right?
Shure: 我刚刚换裤子换一半没换完他出来
Shure: I was halfway through changing my pants when he came out
Shure: 然后就叭
Shure: And then, bam
Shure: 把门敞开
Shure: He left the door wide open
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahahaha
其他人：我不是给你关上了吗
Others: Didn't I close it for you?
Jake:戴眼镜的问题
Jake: It's about wearing glasses
Jake:没有呵呵呵
Jake: No, hahaha
Shure: 这肯定这边没有摄像头吧
Shure: There's definitely no camera here, right?
Shure: 啊OK
Shure: Ah, okay
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no
Jake:你说哪边
Jake: Which side are you talking about?
Shure: 我说这这边
Shure: I mean this side
Jake:有有有这么个方向
Jake: Yes, there is a camera in this direction
Shure: 就是啊那没事
Shure: Oh, then never mind
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay
Jake:这是你的重生之日吗
Jake: Is today your rebirth day?
其他人：是我姥姥忌日
Others: It's my grandma's memorial day
Shure: 呵呵
Shure: Haha
Shure: 呵唉
Shure: Hah, oh well
Shure: 真不见外
Shure: You really aren't shy
Shure: 怎么喜喜欢share一下
Shure: Why do you like to share so much?
Shure: 是吗哈哈哈
Shure: Right? Hahaha
其他人：对不起
Others: Sorry
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Shure: 我怎么穿上跟流氓一样
Shure: Why do I look like a thug in this?
其他人：我就说这件衣服跟你像
Others: I told you this outfit suits you
其他人：那件特别像
Others: That one especially suits you
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah
Jake:挺好看的嗯
Jake: It looks really good, hmm
Shure: 行我穿上了
Shure: Alright, I'm wearing it
Jake:有什么链啊
Jake: Do you have any chains?
Shure: gold
Shure: Gold
Jake:gold
Jake: Gold
Shure: yes
Shure: Yes
Shure: big gold chain you know
Shure: Big gold chain, you know
Alice:这谁的眼镜吗
Alice: Whose glasses are these?
Shure: 啊我的我的我的
Shure: Ah, mine, mine, mine
Shure: 谢谢哦这小哨我拿着
Shure: Thanks, oh this whistle, I'll take it
Shure: 卧槽这这一身太搭了简直
Shure: Whoa, this outfit is just perfect
Shure: 拿个小扇
Shure: Holding a small fan
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Shure: 文胸武肚生道领
Shure: Wenxiong, Wudu, Shengdao collar
Shure: 那我应该我是文还是武文吧
Shure: Should I be Wen or Wu? Wen, I guess
Shure: 卧槽哈哈
Shure: Whoa, haha
Shure: 太帅了真是
Shure: So handsome, really
Shure: 你们有要取的快递吗
Shure: Do any of you have packages to pick up?
Jake:嗯嗯嗯群里面看看吧
Jake: Hmm, check in the group
Jake:群里喊一声
Jake: Announce it in the group
Jake:你们有快递
Jake: You have packages
Jake:取不去
Jake: Are you going to pick them up?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No
Jake:那你们
Jake: Then you all...
Shure: 我要去买一张刮刮乐
Shure: I'm going to buy a scratch-off ticket
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈行行行
Jake: Hahahahaha, alright, alright
Jake:建立一些莫名其妙的联系
Jake: Establishing some inexplicable connections
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it
Shure: 门要关吗
Shure: Should we close the door?
Jake:关呗
Jake: Close it
Shure: 那好吧
Shure: Alright then
Shure: 我记不住密码往那边走
Shure: I can't remember the password, let's go that way
Shure: 他不够皮了就哈哈
Shure: He's not mischievous enough, haha
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Shure: 这得配人字拖
Shure: This needs flip-flops
Shure: 去跟人科要一双
Shure: Go ask someone for a pair
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
其他人：我刚想说你就变成我爹了是吗
Others: I was just about to say, did you become my dad or what?
其他人： 真帅呀
Others: So handsome
Shure: 他的头发很好
Shure: His hair is great
Shure: 我只能说
Shure: I can only say
Shure: 羡慕
Shure: Envy
其他人：真帅呀
Others: So handsome
Shure: 打不到闪靓仔哎呦
Shure: Can't hit the sparkling guy, oh my
Shure: 为什么你穿着那破拖鞋
Shure: Why are you wearing those broken slippers
其他人：但我感觉我今天穿
Other: But I feel like what I wore today
其他人：不是我我昨天今天这两天穿的
Other: No, I mean what I wore yesterday and today
其他人：就是整一身就很适合他
Other: It's just that the whole outfit suits him
Shure: 适合什么
Shure: Suits what?
其他人：仁科
Other: Renke
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay
Shure: 是往这边走吧
Shure: We're supposed to go this way, right?
其他人：我怎么知道
Other: How would I know?
Shure: 这怎么瞅着像个死路呢
Shure: Why does this look like a dead end?
其他人：这可能可以套在任何一个搞摇滚的
Other: This could probably fit any rocker
Shure: 文艺毕生哈哈哈
Shure: Artsy life, hahaha
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哎
Shure: Hahahaha, hey
其他人：这个这个也是个水墨
Other: This, this is also ink
其他人：应该是个竹差不多
Other: It should be bamboo, about right
Shure: 差不多
Shure: About right
Shure: 高晓松哈哈哈
Shure: Gao Xiaosong, hahaha
Shure: 想来唱吧长跑
Shure: Wants to sing and do long runs
Shure: 梳长头发
Shure: Grow long hair
Shure: 我们就叫他高晓松
Shure: He's our Gao Xiaosong
其他人：但是他长发比短头发好看
Other: But his long hair looks better than short hair
其他人：呜这个小白楼
Other: Ooh, this little white building
Shure: 呜
Shure: Ooh
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Shure: 啊到闪亮在一样
Shure: Ah, just like Shining Zai
Shure: 穿着大波
Shure: Wearing a big wave
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 我好像真走错了
Shure: I think I really went the wrong way
其他人：你出来遛弯来了是吧
Other: Are you out for a walk or what?